[Musique]
pourquoi tu es venu ici lives
qu'est ce qui était vrai autant
tout va bien
sache que ça n'était pas ta phu
vous
à
dakar les secours viendront pas
personne c'est cool
tout seul
vous êtes sur la messagerie
je ne suis pas en mesure de décrocher
mon téléphone est mort je suis perdue en
plus de forêts
personne ne va venir te chercher
parce que personne en a rien à [ __ ]
tout rien ni personne ne viendra en aide
c'est sûr que ça va
et là dessus
les livres de beaux actifs toi un peu
debout les jeux tu dois aller de l'avant
tu sais pourquoi il ya des étoiles dans
le ciel nul blanc pourquoi
pour qu'on puisse retrouver le chemin de
sa maison